[Music]
what's up dickies there come stickers it
is monday morning march 7th
on this very special edition of the shop
show welcome
i say kid i was really welcome adults
grown men
my crowd's a real wienerfest we know
this so what's happening man um
yeah man it's uh the fight world is
popping as usual the fight world is
popping uh had a great weekend we had a
calabasas fight companion um it was a
long time coming finally josh barnett
and i were able to link up with matt
matrione and do a calabash fight command
for ufc 272
um you know what's interesting is you
know barnett's been in the fight game
for i don't know 25 years and him and i
have never really crossed paths we had a
bunch of mutual friends
um
you know
um
we we just know
a lot of the same people but we've never
really connected and he's a la guy he
lives in hollywood so he's not far from
me but we just never connected and then
uh mitrione and him know each other
really well they used to train together
and so i was excited to get them on
um because i had mentioned the map
before when matt was talking about josh
i was like oh dude he's one of my bucket
list guys i'd love to have on
so uh the war master came on
and boy he is uh
you know you always have certain
expectations of of guys especially
fighters or comics or
whoever i have on the shows and i you
know i obviously josh burnett has been
on rogan and i talked to rogan about
he's like you smart dude you know you're
going to love them and so you have these
expectations but he exceeded all that
men he's just
a smart bad mama jamma he's just a smart
smart dude uh
as tough as all get out you know just a
legend of of the sport and his knowledge
on history and fighting and cars he's a
gearhead and then you know he's just uh
he's fantastic man because you know we i
if i have matt on you know matt can talk
matt's a chatty kathy so i never get
worried about matt um you just don't
josh and i don't know each other i know
you know with rogan he's a you know he
can talk but
you know sometimes you're in situations
where you book guys and
if you don't know each other or they're
not part of the crew
some guys shell up there's guys who you
know when the cameras aren't on they're
amazing you'd be like oh my god this guy
could make millions of dollars in
podcasting and you know talking being an
analyst when the cameras turn on and
just the dynamics different or maybe
they're in a bad mood you never know man
but josh barnett was not one of those
guys he freaking
saved the day man and i'm forever
grateful to him and we'll get him on a
flashback fight night in a food truck
that's for damn sure i could talk to him
for
days days days days so imagine a
flashback fight night with josh barnett
they'd be we can't limit the three fight
no you can't that has to be
you could even just skip food truck just
do a flashback fight night because he's
gonna have six to ten fights i mean he's
fought everybody though you go through
the pride days all that stuff what the
pancreas days
he's just a legend man so
um he brought his whiskey
i know whiskey
i would say i have my blue belt and
whiskey in bourbon he is a straight
black belt the stuffiest time i was like
oh my god this dude is
balls deep in whiskey
and i love that his whiskey um you know
the warmaster edition of it his is
different than mine it's a smoky flavor
but god damn is it good
it is good man his is selling out and
his is a little different than mine they
do it out of i think said oxnard
california which i love when it's uh
distilled and made you know in local in
california and he's crushing it man he's
just crushing it the war bringer there
it is
yeah that was nice it was really really
nice man
so hopefully hopefully that takes off
for him i know it's
you know crushing it already but
it was good it was strong did you try it
chin i feel like you'd like it i don't
think i tried it so i'm gonna all right
why you didn't try it we'll try it on
fire in the kid all right cool yeah sure
yeah it's a if you like like which i
thought you did you like like that smoky
i like your whiskey so something around
that kind of thing yeah more smooth yeah
his is smooth but smokey it's good it's
and then cast strength too so it's it's
strong but that dude is just
a wealth of knowledge
i mean again i refer to myself as a
hypebeast gearhead you know like i know
cars
any car i would say
97 and up
your boy knows what it what's inside out
i know that stuff now can i get in there
and fix the headers and [ __ ] like josh
barnett no no no that's not what he can
who'd do that and when he's talking
about gears and um you know the
transmission and the stick shift and all
that stuff and switching it out i mean
matt thought he was speaking portuguese
you know i'm saying it's just matt was
like i have no idea what you guys are
talking about but it was you know that
dude knows a thing or two about a lot of
things but uh it was it was a fun fight
companion obviously completely different
than the typical fight companions you
know with chris and brian which you know
those guys barely watch the fights
yeah we're silly
it's just you know but that's the plan
man i like to mix it up chris and brian
will be back i think the next one we're
gonna try to do
is for the big ufc fight night which
they should call it fight day but well i
guess it's night in england for the big
ufc and i think that's march what is
that
march 19th
march 19th the aspinall
fight then that card's pretty stacked
did they add till to that card or no
let's see volkov uh aspinal is the
headliner and uh you know espional wins
that one he's gonna jump in the top five
paddy pimp patty on that
arnold allen dan hooker yeah dude look
at this card stacked
quilov paul craig's great fight gunner
nelson silva great fight dude
1pm so that's saturday afternoon
uh i know chris is in i'm gonna figure
out the other guest but
yeah i think you know obviously we do
the big fight nights for uh
jack our boy johnson is fighting as well
kingston alumni
dude it's a really good card and it's
first big card in england in a hot
second so something to celebrate
i think the the poster our boy reuben's
gonna make can be pretty filthy english
inspired which could be really dope but
those fight nights uh campaigns are fun
to do because then you know people don't
have to pay 80 bucks you can turn the tv
on record it listen to us be dummies you
know and do your thing so i i like doing
not just for the huge pay-per-views i
really do
but yeah the the companion
obviously more fight heavy a little more
x's and o's as far as the fight game but
um
it was great man
the card was just okay wouldn't it it
was just okay didn't blow your hair back
um
you know
it was good it was good it was good you
know it's kind of what i expected
obviously
you know getting covered hurt the card a
little bit uh machu chap not stepping up
man is the the ufc when you don't help
them out man they they're gonna
discipline you and you know i guess the
discipline for him is you have to fight
darius now which isn't terrible
discipline and you know i do think he
beats daryush but um
you know it was a quality card um
the the main issue i have our poor boy
brian kelleher who's flat [ __ ] umar
is a com that he's just such a nightmare
to fight yeah um
dustin jacoby
he was the first fight it's so
disrespectful he's the first fight on
the early prelims of ufc fight pass and
on espn plus and i watched it i think
this dude's won six in a row at light
heavyweight and light heavyweights not
that deep dude how is he not ranked
look at this kid what look at this one
two three four
five six seven wins in a row one draw
he's a monster man and then so he won
well i'll count to the ufc fight he won
uh in the contender series dana white's
contender series that's how he got in
the ufc so one two three four five six
fights in a row and he had one draw
split
you know how's it and you look at the
the light heavyweight
like
roster it's not that deep dude
how's he not in there
i mean there's some really good guys up
there yeah there's some really good guy
you tell me he doesn't beat johnny
walker
i'll bet anybody any amount of money you
want right now jacoby starches johnny
warka at number 12.
starchism
brian spann be a good fight you know
jimmy croot you know
uh jamal hill obviously he's on the come
up
i would love to see jacoby versus the
mayor
he's right there technical like striking
too dude throw him in there with anybody
you want anybody want
i'm telling you man thiago santos have
his hands full with joey how that guy's
not ranked in the top 15 is insane
the anybody who makes those rankings in
what world do you not think jacoby went
starch johnny walker in what world are
you living in you have that guy at 12.
based off previous hype get the hell out
of here
drives me nuts dude but back to the card
he was
it's so disrespectful he's your the
guy's one
sit before that five in a row he got him
kicking off the the card on ufc fight
pass which nobody sees you know what i'm
saying so um tim elliott gets it done
uh you're upset that your girl jan lost
marina rodriguez yawn yeah i thought
that was not not a robbery robbery but
she definitely won
and then with the the main card it
kicked off with uh your your boy sergey
and greg hardy
you know that was hardy's last fight on
his ufc contract
he's lost a good i think three in a row
now he's been finished
he just you know
he doesn't look like he was in the best
of shape coming into the fight you know
i know that 265 stuff for him to make as
well he hasn't exactly blown your hair
back with the competition um
you know lots of tibera which is tough
fight for him tied to avasa clearly a
very tough fight for him and then lost
to sergey
you know i i don't know what they're
gonna do with them i really don't it you
know it was a fun experiment um i know
the ufc took some heat signing guy with
his you know the baggage that came with
this i do believe in redemption it's a
little tough when it comes to domestic
violence obviously i don't know the
exact details of all that um but if ufc
didn't take a chance somebody else would
so i get the experiment uh but i think
we've seen his ceiling unfortunately
the ground game
again there's not enough hours in the
day no matter how hard he works at jiu
jitsu in wrestling to make up for that
lost time at his age
um so
the blueprint to beat him is kind of out
and i i don't see him winning a ton of
fights so
obviously people
tune in to watch him fight i i would
assume love him or hate him you're gonna
tune in to watch him fight and if you're
greg hardy hater which he has a ton
rightfully so right with his background
i get it um
i said this on the companion you talk to
den thomas or uh anybody who works with
greg hardy and they're just like man he
just trains his ass off comes in for
work you know he's a sponge he's trying
to get better men and unfortunately the
ufc just isn't the place to try and pick
up that skill set this is what happens
it's it's a marathon not a sprint but if
you get to the ufc
and you don't have the background and
you don't have the experience
the ufc is not the place to get those
that experience because you're getting
the experience but you're losing and
these the ufc just can't put up with it
they just can't so
i'm curious what they do with them you
know he did them a solid fight taking
that volkov fight uh you know
i i don't know what they do with him you
look at the ceiling i just don't know
where who's he gonna be the lower level
guys he's gonna beat but you know when
you've lost four out of six fights
and this isn't a knock on him it's just
reality it's fighting's very black and
white you know but you know in the in
the nfl if you're a starting quarterback
and you throw
you know six
out of eight passes or interceptions
you're not playing football at the
highest level anymore you're just not so
for the ufc you six out of four fights
and you're also
you know tied to avasa
you know top guy
volkov top guy other than that man
it's you know you're not you're not you
know these guys aren't blowing anybody's
hair back you're not you're not beating
or
even competing with world champions you
know so
um
you know the ufc does have a standard
and i think we've seen his ceiling i
think it was a fun experiment i enjoyed
it i enjoy when greg hardy's fighting um
but i think as a business you got to let
him go and see what he wants to do it's
just isn't it it's just
it's a double-edged sword because at his
age and with his athletic ability
you know it's not like he's gonna go to
a regional circuit and get all the
experience and come to the ufc at 40
years old so
you know it was uh it was a fun
experiment
this is typically how it's going to work
out for guys men if you don't have the
background you're fighting at the
highest level the ufc is not where you
want to gain experience it's such a
short-lived career it just is
kevin holland
stoked for him uh went back to
welterweight after a few losses at
middleweight um
pretty loosey-goosey still right not the
most disciplined dude got a little bit
of trouble with uh alex oliveira
the brazilian cowboy
you know he did get his back in the end
of the round he gave a thumbs up um
barnett and i spoke about this on the
fight companion is i i love his antics
inside the octagon it seems natural
seems organic doesn't seem preconceived
he didn't go in there like i'm going to
do this it just seems like that's his
personality and i [ __ ] with it i think
it's pretty dope man so um i'm glad
kevin holland got a win and i'm sure
that was such a relief after all the
pressure and switching camps and you
know training with dc and trying to get
better so uh he's a big welterweight i
think you do a lot of damage there so i
was excited to see him get a win because
i i can't imagine the pressure he was
under
for bryce mitchell and edson barboza you
know bryce mitchell's 15-1 now i think
he's undefeated in the ufc is that right
chin pretty sure undefeated he's not a
female is one losses outside the ufc
you know he's the closest thing we have
to a khabib who's american as far as
what he did to edson barboza now was it
as dominant
of a performance what khabib did i know
uh you know the commentating team
compared it to khabib
no you're also talking about an older
less
motivated
um less in his prime
um that's in barboza but still for bryce
mitchell to his first big step up in
competition to absolutely dominate
dominate you know 30 25 30 26 30 27 come
on whoever that judge is i'm cool with
30 26 30 25 is an absolute freaking beat
down um you know he's making trouble the
first
60 seconds of fight you know with the
leg kicks and outside that he just
completely dominated him obviously bryce
mitchell's been in the news going into
this fight i think he was on the aerial
show talking about
you know vaccines and government stuff
like that
i mean
the people who are upset are we you guys
want to get on there and just you know
not talk about how he feels or stuff
that he's into you'd rather him just be
the the cookie cutter guy who you know
it's a tough camp you know i've been
trading hard hopefully i can get this
win like i hate that [ __ ] and that's
also personalized like bryce mitchell um
is is one of the reason reasons why
mixed martial arts especially the ufc
blew up and skipped all these other
major leagues because you have
personalities like bryce mitchell if
bryce mitchell is in the nba or nfl or
nhl dude they're going to suppress all
this what's great about the ufc and dana
white like do your thing dude do your
thing
like like think about it strickland too
i'm sure like
do your thing but also get off a little
don't do your thing you know what i'm
saying like you can but they're out i'm
sure not saying hey we're not going to
put your main events if you keep talking
like this danny's like do your thing
doug you know so um
you know the the fans that want to harp
on bryce mitchell and his political or
vaccine belief stuff like that i mean
just have a little bit of open mind man
you know the guy's a a professional cage
fighter and one of the best in the world
his next fight to me a big boy too after
you do that that's in barboza it's off
to the races now at featherweight so i'm
excited for him 145 stacked already it's
great to have bryce mitchell in there um
and if i'm bryce mitchell dude keep
living your truth man and i think
one thing that will shut up the the
haters and the naysayers with you is
when you get on the mic and go
so this kid made 90 grand 45 and 45 and
he goes i'm going to donate 45
half of my salary
to a children's hospital to help these
kids out who have no hope
can't hate on that
you know no matter what you side of the
venture on politically or with
government or conspiracies or vaccines
when a guy goes i'm gonna take half of
my salary and give it to sick kids
okay
awesome yeah and then what's dope about
dana he goes the kid made 4945. i told
him keep your money i'll we'll take care
of the 45 dude which is great
i'm dana white saying kevin bryce says
even though he's taking care of it i
still feel like i have to give back yeah
he's still gonna give some money to him
you guys ever seen one of those children
hospitals
no i see commercials and i can't watch
them bro i was do it when i was in the
ufc
they asked me um to visit a children's
hospital i think in san diego
i'd have kids at the time now i
definitely can't do them but at the time
i've always wanted kids i've always had
such a soft spot for kids i love kids
i've always want to be a dad i wish i
had 10 kids nothing is more important
than kids to me
we go in this hospital when we get there
and before we go in
they go uh
hey man so these kids you know you're
gonna see some [ __ ] man you're gonna see
some [ __ ] and these kids everyone comes
in and feels sorry for them give gives
them sympathy and they cry
they don't want they want to be treated
normal so don't let any of this get to
you and i was like i'm fine man yeah i
got this no problem when you go in and
the kid has three months to live or you
know he you know he's
you're talking about brain cancers or
you know the kids missing legs or the
kids there's there's one uh little girl
who's in a bubble she has some rare
disease where if she touches any of the
outside like her immune system she just
she's allergic to everything and she
can't and she also couldn't feel so hot
cold if she's sick she doesn't have that
those feelings the nerves don't do that
so they have to constantly keep her in
this bubble wrap dude
or the kid literally a kid had three
months to live i walked in and dude
i just started crying walked out i was
like i can't do this if i can't cry and
like hug them and touch them i can't do
it i literally i could i physically
couldn't do it it's impossible so i'm
sure bryce mitchell has had some
experience or got some perspective going
into those
and i advise you guys if
you are bryce mitchell hater you don't
even have to be a price mitchell hater
but if you want to
make the world a better place
go visit one of those children hospitals
man it will change your perspective on
everything and you will realize
all the [ __ ] that this rat race that we
care about and you know views and social
media and likes and reposts and retweets
and haters and fans and you realize it
doesn't mean [ __ ] dude there's so much
bigger things going on in this world
like last night i was watching american
idol i'm watching you know i love
american idol i love it there's this
girl who's
she you know there's
uh they know what they're doing they're
telling that this girl's from uh
to see to sigi to sigi alabama to sigi
sigi
yeah she's from sea in alabama and i
think that's where lana richie's from so
he liked her right away pretty girl big
girl thick girl but cool thick you know
not like lizzo thick like cool thing
right
and uh she goes up there but but i knew
they're gonna try and get me to cry
because she grew up like dirt poor
and you know in foster homes the whole
family and they grew up in trailer parks
she's the oldest she was saying how hard
it is and the scrounging for food and
just to make ends meet and her little
brother who turned 16 just was sick of
the rat race took his own life so that's
when she and she's always had this
talent to sing
do she's singing a katy perry song
uh the i'm wide awake dude and katie was
like that's she gets you know katie's
tearing up and katie goes
that's better than what i do she's like
you made one of my hit songs your song
no one can do that
because it's always like such a risk to
sing one of their songs in front of them
because obviously they know the song
like a [ __ ] dude it will give
you chills i
you're not a fr you're a sociopath if
you can watch that and not feel some
type of way you gotta be a goddamn
sociopath she was amazing man you want
her to go on and get all the riches in
the world and take care of her remaining
i think three or four uh brothers and
sisters and her mom you know you're just
like god i hope that girl makes it man
you're just like god i hope she makes it
um
but yeah so all that goes back if if you
you know but the point was i was
watching american idol and as i watched
american idol
i was uh on uh the internet just looking
at ukraine and russia stuff and i'm
watching these people and how obviously
for them it's all you know ignorance is
bliss but also for them it's like this
is their shot and they're singing and
there's judges and there's studio and
they're in nashville in la and you know
there's all this glitz and glamour i'm
just thinking god like i get it from
their perspective they're trying to get
out whatever situation they're in that's
all they know and that's all they can
deal with but there's literally a war
going on right now kids are dying people
are dying they're trying to escape their
homeland it's 222.
and if it's tough not to when you look
at that stuff and you know you're you're
watching things but you know that's
going on it's just so insane to me man
it's so insane
and i i don't i don't know what you can
do those those anonymous guys the
anonymous crew you know what i'm talking
about the anonymous crew who the hackers
who hacked in the russian government and
they hack online and shut them down
stuff like that those those those guys
are doing the lord's work you know
because you know obviously russia's good
at that stuff but
not better than our guys they're just
not and uh that anonymous group is doing
what they can because really what can
you do you're talking about a ma a
madman and you know putin and it's like
what do you do
and he has nuclear weapons what do you
do
you know
and then you know you get in too deep
and they're getting pictures of kids
dying
it's dark it's war dude i saw the videos
and i just can't watch them yeah it it
it literally you know my girl this
morning she was like why'd you change
i'm like i can't i can't start my day
with this stuff because it will
literally
bleed into everything i do no pun intend
it will literally
uh
bleed in hate to say it again we'll
bleed into you know the shop show and i
find the kid later enough my meetings
later we'll bleed into all that stuff
it's just
it's tough to be funny and stuff to be
creative it's just when you know that
stuff is going on
and it makes you would see what you're
doing is just such [ __ ] dude
you know
it's crazy crazy
but that whole long rant is how great of
a person bryce mitchell is for again
think of the salary you make whatever it
is whatever it is everyone's working
their ass off imagine taking half your
salary and donating the sick kids and
you want to hate on bryce mitchell are
you out of your goddamn mind
i don't care again what fence you're on
vaccine anti-vaxx
trump biden
whatever it is flat earth
whatever lizard people i don't give a
[ __ ]
for a kid
and he is a kid for a kid in bryce
mitchell to say hey take half my salary
to make these kids who knows buy them
toys buy them something a lot of them
aren't coming out of that hospital man
how you can hate on that kid is insane
to me insane once bryce did that dude he
could get on there and hate on white
people
hate on uh fighters who were comics hate
on fire she became podcasters he could
hate on whatever he wants he's all good
in my book there's nothing that kid can
do to piss me off
nothing can do i'm a huge bryce mitchell
fan now i'm telling you guys if you're
gonna hate on them
donate half your salary to a children's
hospital you know what and if you can't
do that a lot of us can't if you can't
do that just go visit a hospital bring
toys to a children's hospital and make
it i into two rooms let me know how it
goes for you
let me know how it goes for you
let's take a little break from
everything ufc 272 because man i'm out
there in the streets in l.a i'm on the
streets i'm at the hollywood improv this
wednesday i'm in nashville this week and
i see all the bros out there my crowd
usually real wienerfest and a lot of
y'all got messed up here man you're just
losing your hair you don't know what to
do here's some here's some actual facts
for you two out of three bros will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35. more than 50 million
men in the us suffer from male pattern
baldness but now there's you can do
something about it man you can you're
self-conscious you're wearing hats all
the time wearing beanies left and right
your hair is leaving you you're looking
like george costanza you're worried
about it you're recently single what are
you gonna do with your hair my friends
at keeps got you covered man keeps
offers a simple affordable stress free
way to keep your hair alright it's a
super easy convenient virtual doctor you
meet with and the medications are
delivered straight to your door every
three months you don't have to leave
your crib you have 24 7 care and support
keeps as a net network of expert medical
advisors prescribers care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality you're looking like fabio after
you get done with keeps it's low cost
starts at 10 a month all right
keeps has everything you need to keep
your hair delivered straight to your
door discreet little package proven
results remember prevention is key keep
what you have fellas don't wait your
hair's gonna your hairline's gonna fold
all the way back don't wait don't look
like brian callan treatments can take
four to six months see results so act
right now when it comes to your hair
save more spend less if you're ready to
take action prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com
shobb s-e-h-a-u-b that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com shop to receive your first month
of treatment for free that's keeps.com
shop to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash shop
you know for you dads out there one
thing we love is a green lawn my ficuses
are pop and sun i have a fortress around
my house of green fyxes the lawn is
popping
nothing
nothing
is better than a fresh cut lawn
especially if it's nice and green and
full of life my friends
sunday time about sunday can help you
grow a beautiful lawn without the
guesswork or the nasty chemicals that
are nightmare to deal with not safe for
kids or animals sunday got you covered
man their custom plans include
fertilizer and everything you need to
make it easy to take care of your lawn
so that thing is popping they got
ingredients like seaweed iron molasses
you can feel good with the kids and pets
being around all you have to do is visit
getsunday.com put in your address their
lawn analysis tool does the rest then
they use a soil and climate data to
create a personal nutrient plan
delivered to your door when you need it
just attach the ready-to-use pouch to a
garden hose and spray it takes less than
15 minutes best of all this stuff
actually works i'm telling you all my
freaking ficuses the
lawn is popping there's nothing better
it looks like lambeau field man i'm
telling you and sunday is offering you
guys the dads out there who care about
your lawns they're offering you guys 20
off all right full season plans start
just 129 bucks we're talking about full
season plans 129 bucks you get 20
off at checkout when you visit
getsunday.com
shob20 the the slash shop schab20220
that's 20 off your custom plan to have
the greenest lawn ever on the block
people can be jocking your lawn
getsunday.com20. moving on the co-main
event sorry for that long rant but shout
out to bryce mitchell
um
in the coma event such a shame when you
see fazeev
uh renato
makano meccano you know
you fly me for brazil
i think the fight they should change the
three rounds because already taking a
fight on short notice is such a beast
now you're taking a fight on short
notice but you're doing against dos
anjos who's
literally from top to bottom as far as
record
um
level of difficulty as far as his
opponents there's nobody has more
impressive resume as far as if this
college football uh schedule
he's by far had the toughest go uh in
the u in ufc history as top to bottom
opponents he's faced everybody he's beat
most of them lost to some of them um so
for renato to take the fight in short
notice you're facing rafael dos anjos
there's nothing you can do that he
hasn't seen yet
for whatever reason they kept at five
rounds
you know and it's tough enough to get
ready for three rounds but now you're
short notice five rounds
once that fight was a late replacement
they should have scrapped the five
rounds it's very dangerous renato's
coaches probably after the third could
have tossed in the towel they didn't
um do sanjo's being just
a complete gentleman you won't find a
nice scan that you see than los angeles
maybe wonder boy
moreno's up there there's first team all
nice and dos angel's on that and you
know he's honorable mention at least
he's on that dude he's such a good
person i know first [ __ ] hand such a
good dude
so for him
he could have mollywood ronaldo renato
in that fifth round and he didn't he
didn't i thought he pulled back in that
fifth round otherwise this kid's had
enough i can't believe he's still here i
thought he pulled back
um so for dos sanchos
you know you want the exp
the experience i don't say the
experience guy doesn't need more
experience he needs more experience like
i need a freaking std he um
[Music]
you know you want a paycheck and you
know you had this camp so you want to
pay off
but this beating renato on short notice
in a five-round co-main event does
nothing for you as far as moving up in
the queue or your next match up
so i know he got in the mic and said
that physique fight's over
and i thought about this and
originally no matter what happened this
fight i thought he was gonna beat uh
renato 100 but going into this fight i
thought oh i definitely want him to
reschedule the physique fight right
they're supposed to fight originally on
a fight night and it's gonna be a main
event five rounds
but what the ufc is doing here is pretty
clear with what they're doing is it's a
huge step up for ziv but for fazeev
rafael fazeeb what they're doing there
is they're doing faziva favor they're
not doing dos angels a favor he's fought
everybody dude he the the fizzy does
nothing for dos sanjo's resume
but what they're gonna what they're
trying to do is they think it's a tough
matchup for dos anjos they think maybe
you know he's over the hill he's long on
the tooth so it's just a launching
platform for fazeev so when i think
about it
i guess dos angelo's right he's like i'm
good man the fight didn't happen
i don't want to fight him we're moving
on but originally i was like definitely
make that fight again
but i think for dos angels it's about
moving up towards getting another title
shot or getting big money fights you
want those big money fights so doe
sanchos who's a brilliant man and
phenomenal father by the way which is
really important here but dos anjos goes
all right how what's going to get me
closer title shot or what's going to get
me paid and he must have thought about
this because he goes i would love a
connor fight
at first i kind of flinched him honor
come on don everybody wants conor right
what do you think about that makes a lot
of sense counterfeit makes a lot of
sense depending what they want to do
with connor connor
connor and hopfield dos and just makes a
lot of sense not a terrible fight for
connor
great fight for dos sanchos dos angels
yeah a little bit longer tooth but still
very dangerous
you could definitely
you know if conor were to go on there
and beat him definitely a title shot
after that you know
so
for conor we got to be a little dicey
you know with the makeup fight make this
if you're a conor fan that you do you do
not trust me you do not want that
so for dos anjos he said
you know i want connor or i want uh
makachev
i i can agree more with them you know
it's very rare i agree with guys after
post fight conferences it's very when
they do call out somebody come on dude
because after they shoot for the moon
hopefully to land on the stars and we'll
get to that with colby covington but uh
for dos sancho's like mock chef makes a
lot of sense
you know he's he's the next thing even
though they said he has to fight uh
daryush next you know how the ufc goes
they say that's trying to discipline him
but
if they're going to have to give him a
fight
makachev or um
uh
conor makes a lot of sense for him
it really does make sense for dos
angelos they're supposed to if you
remember they're supposed to fight
originally they're originally slated to
fight so i think if you're in the
counter business that's a winnable fight
not an easy fight i'm not saying that in
any facet but
it's winnable we could see we could see
kind of winning that fight
um so
i moved on from the physique fight i
think there's other fighting to do with
fazeev i think still you know has a
little bit of ways to go before he
fights and catapults a win over
dos angels do i think you'd beat do
sanchos after seeing that dos angels on
saturday night i don't know that's a
tough fight for physique man it's a very
tough fight very very tough fight
um he could definitely get it done but i
just feel like there's some other stuff
fazeev could do before he just jumps up
to do sanchos at six and for dos anjos i
feel like he's done enough
in the organization to to say i'm gonna
physical at 11 dude i'm six i just beat
those two wins and ride fought paul
felder on short notice and i fought
freaking you know uh renato
on a short notice
like give me the work with me here mock
chefs ahead of you you beat him you're
sure sell closer title shot connor you
beat him you're you know your name's
huge and you get a payday and these kids
i'm all for it man so um hopefully that
works out for him and you know dana in
the ufc is going to discipline mike jeff
i would have loved to see makachev dos
angels on that i'm so surprised mark
jeff turned the fight down
so surprised
i wonder where that doesn't seem like
his style don't i wonder because he was
out he's like i'm down to go again no no
shade on makjev at all because i heard
he was down to go even blasts out on
social media i was like hey put me in
there cool you're in and then somewhere
along the way
i don't know if it's his team or what
but i would be willing to bet makachev
wasn't like i'm not taking that i don't
think so i don't think so i i bet his
team was like no we're gonna wait and
they thought just wait for a tile shot
if nothing to win but when you play with
ufc and you don't help them out they're
gonna disappoint so now you're gonna
have to fight him or darius next so
we'll see
but uh shout out to dos angels man just
a solid dude one of the best ever do it
i hope he gets that connor fight or the
maka chef fight next mock chef fight
very tough fight for him
obviously i'm high mike jeff as you can
tell of course
and the main event um you know first
time in a ufc pay-per-view where you got
two guys
who aren't title holders you know main
eventing a big ufc pay-per-view and um
you know you had
like actual truly bad blood you're
talking about former best friends former
roommates uh colby obviously left att
for a variety of reasons ones was what
he says is jorge mazurl and others
dustin poirier
um
you know i thought jorge it's just
stylistically he's a bad matchup for him
um kobe was just all over him the the 50
44 50 40. 50 45 seems more reasonable to
me the 4946 i can see when you know
jorge did wobble him
but you know after that colby still for
the rest of that round you know warm out
like a backpack
colby's rest wrestling was just too much
jorge was just on his back foot or
constant defense takedowns couldn't get
off
when colby did decide to play that you
know striking game
he was lighting them up but then you
know he it was a level playing field
because jorge lands one you saw happen
so colby got smart and just wore his ass
out um you know again despite what the
haters or what you know the the people
think of colby compton he's the best
welterweight on the planet not named
kamar hussman
that being said what's next for kobe
commenting
he's lost twice to camaro
one was kind of close right one was kind
of close i heard camaro he was doing a
uh you know before the the weigh-ins
they they have a fighter come out and do
a q a and someone said you know if colby
wins would you give him another title
shot
and uh kamar goes
um would you guys like to see it do you
think i be
who thinks colby won that fight when it
went to rarely went to decisions who
thinks kobe won that fight and the crowd
started sharing he goes this way i'd
fight him again i'll make it very clear
that i'm way better than kobe kellington
so i don't think it's an x obviously uh
leon edwards is next and i know kamar
usman says he wants to be active this
year
and he also wants a fight with canelo
which i just don't see happening
he said canelo's team was kind of into
it i you know i i just don't see that
happening
i love and this is what makes kamar
usman so great his mentality he goes i
believe i can stop him i don't care what
you guys think you know is if i believe
it i don't care what anybody else says
and that's why you know he's the pound
for pound goat right now
so um
i would watch colby and camaro spin
fight every saturday night i'll do a
fight paint every saturday night if i
could for that fight
i you know so i just don't think the ufc
is gonna do that next so i think colby
knows that's not next right because he's
fighting leon edwards so kobe being
colby called out dustin poirier
when i first heard the call out i'm like
okay that makes sense
it makes sense it's a big fight for
colby it's like you're ranked number two
you're right number one in the world
you're by far number one
so
you can do one of two things you can go
for the big money fights
you know mozzarella was a money fight
and there's bad blood there does some
poor a's a money fight doesn't make a
lot of sense because you beat doesn't
pour a still just the number one 170 in
the world but you guys have that att bad
blood but you just did that
so you could do it again and you know
the gym rivalry and stuff like that
um and i know dustin perry is like tells
him it's on site he can't stand him he
goes i see you we're gonna fight in the
streets i don't want you get paid off me
but i think you know money does talk so
i think ufc could throw somebody doesn't
pour his way
but i'm with dana
and and dana goes
let's say we make that dustin pouring
fight then what do we do doesn't before
he's not at 170. so what do we like
where does it put colby i think kobe's
like i'm number one dude i'm not trying
to fight guys who are lower
the only argument there if you're a
purist too you don't like these weird
like super money fights right you don't
like these
kind of super ball-ish you know super
fights so i think
if if you look at the division there's a
lot of formal opponents men there's a
lot of guys a lot of guys who he hasn't
fought vicente luke
muhammad have to fight the winner of
that i would assume uh is right there um
and then again
to me kobe compton should fight the
winner of hamza gilbert burns that's the
fight that's as a pure standpoint as uh
um you know just uh if you want to keep
the game pure and you want to do what's
right
um
hanzo is undeniable and if he were to
um i think he fights april 9th on the
next pay-per-view he's the third fight
on that main card if hamza were to just
absolutely storm through gilbert burns
he's gonna jump to number two in the
world
and for colby it's gonna be tough to
ignore him then and the ufc also
realizes that they have something in
hamzad he's kind of your next coming of
a conor mcgregor khabib-ish kind of a
blend he's a he's a monster dude um and
i do think he starts just gilbert burns
i really do and if he were to do that i
think colby's going to be forced to take
a hamzap fight
and as good as kobe is again i know
listen nobody jerks off
makachev and hamza more than i do
i just i don't i'd love to hear the
argument that hamzad's gonna lose
i just you know i don't think he i don't
know who beats him
until i see him you know in some trouble
or somebody stop some it's been a a
whirlwind a dakistan
sweden whirlwind of him just
dominating guys in every facet of the
game so we haven't seen a [ __ ] in his
armor
and stylistically
for him to go to 11 to two he's
obviously jump in the queue rightfully
so the talent and hype is there and he's
dominated guys no one's giving him any
issues
but there's tougher matchups besides
gilbert burns for him but the ufc
realizes they they've struck gold with
him and there's something
something special about hamzap man and
boy is it off to the races i told you
guys this it's off to the races if he be
if he beats gilbert burns
and depending what they want to do with
kobe if colby's being difficult i would
be willing to imagine again kamar say he
wants to be active this year there's a
chance hamzad beats gilbert and then
they give him camaro
there's a chance for that but depending
how
you know camaro and leon edwards does
goes down if there's injuries if who
knows poke in the eye groin whatever
you know
there could it could be forced to have
harms out versus kobe compton but kobe
hamza the [ __ ] talking in that and
here's the difference it's cody talks a
lot of [ __ ] and i love it it's his style
i love it sometimes he was a little
overboard especially when talked about
mazda being a bad dad and side pieces or
girlfriends or whatever
you talk like that the hamsad bro i
don't know if there's enough ufc
security to stop him and his boys from
roughing you up before the fight man
you're talking with some real tough
dudes man
i don't i don't i just
i know it sounds like i'm all up on
hamzat's chin strap beard but
so be it man i just style asleep i don't
know who beats him
i don't until i see a [ __ ] in his armor
i'm riding the [ __ ] out of his hairy
nuts i just am
so for colby the dustin poirier fight
you know dana didn't seem too keen on it
uh i think dustin poirier he's also
looking for super fights uh you know he
wants that nate diaz fight
um
so i i just don't see it happening for
colby i think colby's going to be forced
to fight uh the likes of ahamzat the
winner of hamzat um
gilbert burns or he's going to fight
muhammad or mohammed
vicente luke winner
and again there's a lot of formal
opponents at 170. you don't need to jump
around weight classes and clog it up you
know you don't there's too much there is
a purist i'd like to see them fight
these other guys as colby as a
businessman you're like i'm gonna fight
the winner of muhammad vicente luki i i
just i've been fighting monsters dude
like big big stars man you know so
it's gonna be interesting um
and then for jorge maswa doll
i'm not
in the same agreement from a lot of mma
experts in the space who are like you
know for jorge is long on the tooth but
why because he lost to kobe compton
kamar hoosman
okay
um yeah i know some people say they want
to see him fight nate diaz next i'd
rather see a dustin pouring eight diaz
we saw mazuro on ideas that does nothing
for me um as much as i love nate diaz
nate diaz pourism to me is a funner
fight we've seen how it goes with mazda
all in ideas
for mazeldoll
you know i i think though the biggest
fight they could make for him is conor
mcgregor because conor mcgregor is super
juicy right now not saying you soda
juicy i'm just saying juicy thick in a
good way so i i think 55 is out of the
question for conor he's gotten too big
he's too much time off he's put on a lot
of muscle
you tell me jorge connor doesn't sell
gangbusters
and as much as they're paying maslow
he's the third highest-paid ufc fighter
ever
will for the ufc when they make that
investment i don't know how much he's
getting paid has to be a truckload
you're not fighting the muhammad and
vicente luki's of the world that's not
happening anymore they got to get a
return on their investment the biggest
return they can get is conor mcgregor
mazdal makes a lot of sense
so i think and again if you're in a
conor mcgregor camp your dick writer
like i am
the mazda doll is a winner will fight
and also mazda is a natural 155 or so is
conor county fight at 45 right so
mazda doll small for 170. you know nate
diaz even though he fights at 55 he's a
bigger dude i just think the mazdal
fight makes more sense mazda's not just
you know
some washed up old veteran he's kind of
come into his own and i i think a
mazadal conor mcgregor makes the
absolute most sense for a huge huge
pay-per-view really do sign me up
um
there's one guy who knows this sport
there's probably a bunch of guys but
there's one guy who i consider a friend
who knows colby better than any of us he
also knows the sport of mixed martial
arts in the ufc better than i do and
that is trail sonin and so uh i'm gonna
sit down
and uh zoom in with a call with chael
sonnen who's one of the only guys busier
than i am so as much as i want to get
them in here for a food truck and
flashback which we will
the best we can do now with our
schedules is a zoom call you guys know i
usually hate zoom but i will take it if
it's jail sonin so let's chat fisticuffs
with chael soden before i chat with my
brother from a different fighting mother
chael sonnen hey man
let's take a little break gotta keep
these lights on gotta pay the employees
all right and online shopping isn't
slowing down anytime soon is your
business ready to keep up with the pace
are you stressed out listen shipping's a
beast your boy used to deal with it
before i hired a company to deal with it
before i started using ship station with
ship station you never have to worry
again about shipping all right make the
switch to a solution that handles all
your shipping needs quickly it's
affordable it's painless ship station is
already trusted by over 100 000
ecommerce sellers keep track of orders
from any sales channel easily find the
best shipping carrier with deep
discounted rates all right
save time because you can funnel all
your orders in one simple interface no
matter where you're selling manage every
order amazon ebay etsy your own freaking
merch or website whatever you're trying
to sell you save money uh save your
sanity man it's a beast out there no
wonder 98 of companies that use ship
station for a year keep using it for as
long as they're in business it's that
freaking good ship more and less time
with shipstation use my code shobb
schaub to get 60 day free trial that's
two months free of no hassle stress free
shipping try it out got nothing to lose
just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page right type in shop
s-c-h-a-b
ship station make ship happen
mr trail sonan dude you got to be one of
the busiest guys in the world you're one
of the only people that i would do a
zoom call with but i know how busy you
are man i've been trying to get you out
here for a while i keep harassing you so
all we got is a zoom but i'll take it
i'll take it sir i'll take it hey i'm
busy right next to you and i wish i was
with you just so we could have a nice
meal because you're always good at
providing those and i'm coming off of a
pizza hot pizza hut stuffed crust i
gotta tell you two thumbs down the
commercial look great i want my twenty
dollars back that's what you get for
buying pizza hut chill you make too much
money you're too busy to eat pizza hut
man we've moved on from pizza hut dude
so what's up man did you watch the
fights this weekend did you see this was
this the lightest pay-per-view of all
time
i love you you know what i i did a
cowbest fight companion show with josh
barnett and matt matrione and uh josh
barnett had nothing but great things to
say about you he was saying how he
wishes you were there with us and i
couldn't agree more
um we watched the fights
you know
it's not a a pay-per-view card that's
going to blow your hair back
one of the reasons i want to talk to you
i'll see you you're very close with
colby
and my my thing going this fight the
fight went how i thought it was going to
go you know i i we i think we both uh
work with draftkings and they always ask
me to make pics and stuff like that and
i told people i said
this fight's a little different just
because these guys know each other so
well they've trained together they lived
together when when two friends are
fighting
kind of everything else goes out the
window if they know each other that well
but it was like it didn't matter what
muzzled all did colby was just too much
for men just way too much
and brennan i i would love if somebody
studied this but any time two guys know
each other and it's not just fighting it
could be when tom brady leaves the paris
patriots goes to the buccaneers and the
buccaneers travel back to new england
okay we know each other but what that
means it flips a switch psychologically
inside of every athlete defensive i know
what he likes to do i'm going to know
how to block i'm going to see his setup
so i'll know when to get out of the way
it's a defensive mindset and in this
sport of ours of mma it's about
aggression it's about attacking and
anytime two guys know each other it ends
up being a little bit dull it just does
i think colby covington in the very
first round of that very first takedown
attempt was met with more resistance
than he was expecting because colby's
output in the first 10 to 12 minutes was
the lowest in the history of colby's
career but i think he got a respect from
osborne i think he he felt real quick
okay this guy knows what i like to do oh
by the way he's elbowing me in the head
oh by the way he's not a 155 pounder
anymore and i kind of got a sense
even if it's bad for kobe at the
beginning he's gonna he's gonna pick it
up as he as he gets closer to the finish
line he's gonna put his foot down a
little bit more that's what it looked
like happened and i'm not sure both guys
didn't do what they said they were gonna
do colby said i'm gonna go up there and
beat mosby did i never heard roswell say
that once moswell said i'm going to hit
him i'm going to hurt him i'm going to
expose the mazda the build-up to this
fight never once said he was going to
beat him i don't think that's what it
was about for george george wanted to
get locked in there regardless of the
embarrassment the one he wanted to hit
that guy in the face i think they both
left with what they want i think so i
the fight was a little bit of a letdown
yeah is that fair to say also
going back to guys fighting each other
that know each other have you fought a
training partner throughout the years
because i used to train with andre
orlosky all the time and then the ufc
called us to fight each other
man we i'm talking we sparred rounds and
rounds and rounds throughout my training
and throughout my career at greg
jackson's and we fought each other he
knew what my best tools were i knew what
his best tools i knew his takedowns i
knew you know what he was really good at
what he was bad at and it was a boring
fight it was just a bad fight we were
both tentative nobody really let their
hands go i would take him down you know
it was just it wasn't a fun fight so
that's why i said if you're gonna bet on
this it you know obviously kobe is the
favorite for the for a reason but it you
know it wasn't it wasn't a great fight
man it just wasn't i think for colby a
finish would have been great but he's
done enough to he's in a he's in a weird
spot now like what would you say but
i don't want to skip past i'm assuming
you've fought training partners before
before we go to what snakes for colby
yeah
to answer the training partner question
yes i've had to compete with guys i
trained with but that was all the way
back in college i would have a roommate
where we would do more homework together
we would ride to class together we're in
the same weight class brenda we would
have to go into the restroom shake hands
and have a wrestle off then get in the
sin and drive home together one of us
devastated one of us moving on it was
just very weird the biggest thing that i
can tell you is that's where the most
pressure is and guys like you and i
always tell the audience who has the
pressure but we don't always take time
to explain to the audience why that
matters
pressure creates a chemical release that
creates a fatigue whoever is feeling
more pressure whoever is more nervous
than tied to an emotion any emotion is
going to get tired a little bit faster
that's why guys like you and i try to
identify who it is and try to imagine
what's on somebody's shoulder so i do
think that that explains a little bit of
the the output and when you talk about
where does colby go from here
colby's doing everything right brendan
in the last one week
and i'm defining a week by five days in
the last five days he has said i am the
number one contender and i have proven
it he's right he is the only guy ranked
number one in the whole sport that
doesn't get a fight for the championship
he's in a unique spot he already did
twice against the same guy history of
the sport says we don't go to number
three if the outcomes of one and two
weren't split so what does he do he
comes up with an idea he goes to a press
conference says i'm going to take this
golden ticket i'm going to cash it in
against honasanya dana white quite
literally laughed okay fine colby didn't
get that one so next time he's got a
microphone in his hand he goes after
dustin poirier now dustin poirier is not
a 170 pounder but if you do look at what
kobe did he called out kamar guzman
which he couldn't get he called out
assange when she got laughed at he
called out dustin poirier who's not in
the division those are three hammers the
one thing those three guys have in
common is world championship belts colby
is not asking for something easy he just
realizes i don't get what every other
number one contender gets i don't get
the title shot so give me out something
big and the one the one takeaway that i
did get from colby going in three vastly
different directions his own weight
class a weight class down in a weight
class is that he sees what you and i are
talking about he sees he's in a unique
spot he's trying to make the best he can
with it but everybody's telling him he's
wrong he can't be wrong non-stop even a
broken clock is right twice a day
colby's just waiting for something to
come back and you want to know who
called colby covington out between those
three weight classes nobody brendan they
don't want to fight the guy it means
you're going to get a main event it
means you're going to get a sold out
arena it means you're going to get a lot
of really great things they still don't
want it yeah i think for kobe's he's in
a tough spot again i would watch camaro
and kobe fight every saturday i'd be
happy with that take my 80 bucks i love
that fight i think you know colby could
make some changes maybe
you know get a win here or there against
camaro but kobe is your reigning
champion if he was just born five years
before or five years later he's the best
170 on the planet or not named kamar
hoosman so
for colby
you know he he he shoots for the moon
hoping to land on the stars obviously
the izzy fights not happening um
i like his call outs i'm a huge fan of
colby i know you are too you're very
close with them but
the dustin poiret and you could see even
dana goes what are we going to do with
that you know he's not even a true
one-seven year you went you win that
fight you're still number one
i think as a purist and where he's going
to get some kind of backlash there is
there's some affordable you know i was
talking about before he came on there's
some really good 170 ears coming up a
guy who i think kobe's going to have to
address very soon is hamzad i think
hamzad is the next big thing and i i do
see maybe the ufc forcing kobe's hand to
take that fight if he's going to stay at
170.
see i think he's going to have to get
creative too when you have the number
one guy and the one thing that usman
versus covington part 2 really did show
us is that we found the right two guys
there's a bit of a separation now i am
also a little bit drunk on the on the
hazmat chimaya uh you know i think that
the excitement of him i got to see him
for the first time i happened to be at
the pi i was doing something totally
unrelated he was upstairs i went and
watched a workout he was working out
with latifi i was invited to come back
the next day for sparring with latifi
chimaya uh gustafson and till i was
planning to go and and bryn i was gonna
take a camera i even asked him can i
film this they said yes and i got called
espn called me so i i am not getting to
do that but the rumors are true the the
guy's as good as all these practice
rooms uh stories that keep on coming out
the other side of the coin i've always
wondered on shamaya why he's going after
170. if all things are equal and he
makes it to a title fight you ultimately
just have to ask yourself is he more
likely to beat out of sonya with his
skills or is he more likely to beat usma
with with his skills he told me chill
i've heard you say that before but i
don't weigh 185 i always gave up weight
he said the heaviest that i ever have
been in my life is 181 pounds so for
right now he is a 70 pounder i know he's
got big goals in this champ champ champ
thing lots of guys do but right now he
still does that smoke dana gave us one
clue on chicamia and the last time david
spoke about jemiah he said he's four
wins away from being considered for a
world title
amen dana now recently came out saturday
post fight press conference and said i
believe chemi versus burns is the number
one contenders fight now all of this uh
that i'm giving you is to answer your
question in terms of what does colby do
because i agree with you i think if you
beat burns you're probably fighting for
a bell i think if you beat chemi or if
you beat colby you're probably going to
be going and fighting for a belt i know
luke and blah muhammad will have their
own thing to say about that but the
point is everybody's busy that's my only
point everybody's tied up and we will do
rematches winners for championships we
don't use usually do that for contenders
matches so colby who really has ran
through a division successfully not only
not losing fights he's not even losing
rounds it's a tough thing to find where
he goes i don't begrudge dana for the
responsible what would him and dustin be
fighting for i do start to begrudge that
was colby's third idea in five days and
all of them got told no well nobody's
challenging him and colby's not looking
to just go after anything he's a main
event guy he wants to sold out house
he's earned that i mean he sold his soul
for this thing right the gimmick is gone
the gimmick is so far off the rails that
everybody must just decide we don't like
him we're not going to give him anything
he wants well he come on he gets
something but i i do think with colby
you know i i'm all about him getting
paid you know the dustin poirier is a
super fight the izzy's a super fight
i'm all about those super fights i i
like when guys get paid the most amount
of money get the most eyeballs on them
colby deserves it he's beaten everybody
not named kamara usman
if he were to fight hamza and obviously
we're going to find out a lot about
hamza when he fights gilbert burns and i
have my thoughts on that
and you know the stories about hamzat
how do you think colby would match up
against hamzat i think it's a very tough
fight for colby stylistically
yeah yeah and look momentum is real and
all sports momentum is real there is
nobody with with the wind in his back
right now as jemima i do think that's
real now between the two of them what
we've seen we have not seen hamza deal
with adversity that we have no reason to
believe he can't deal with it but he
hasn't proved it yet we have no reason
to believe that hamza could not enter
the five round club but he hasn't yet
colby has i just think there's a couple
of things that we're going to be fair
with the rankings i think the rankings
do have it right i think it showed the
respect to the guy that they got this
close versus the guy who's brand new and
only did two fights in the division
against unranked opponents i do see what
you see i am not part of dismissing
jamaica i think there's something real
there but when you do come down to the
really hard matchups and i say this as a
wrestler it's a guy that likes to get
somebody and take him down see that
that's what hoswells likes to do i think
putting him against camaro's heart kamar
is a national champion in that very
sport put him with colby covington who
is fifth uh in the division one ranks i
think that it's very hard those are the
appropriate matches but if colby is to
get to that let's go back to what dana
did say when he dismissed uh the pouring
fight what are we gonna do what's this
about what's it for great but colby
needs to get that answer if he's gonna
go in there and do this heavy lifting
against the chimaya he needs to have an
answer to that question what is this for
because there's ways that colby returns
to a world title fight and even a world
championship those waves just involve
kamara oozman no longer having the belt
yeah and you know camaro's talking about
fighting uh you know canelo and doing
that stuff and he has the leon edwards
fight
so i'm with colby man i don't have you
know he's like what are we doing i'm
throwing all this mud at the wall
hopefully something sticks you keep
shooting it down it sounds like he just
needs to be told all right we're waiting
for the winner of gilbert hamzat or
muhammad and uh vicente luke
you're going to get one of those guys
you know but
if i'm colby
you know a vicente lucay
muhammad fight doesn't you know doesn't
do a ton for me especially at the level
he's at
again i keep going back to it the winner
of hamzat and gilbert burns to me makes
the most sense especially for colby but
again if if the plan is if all kobe
cares about is getting another title
shot to kamarusman it's going to go
through hamzad i really think so so i
would be willing to bet again you know
colby ben and i do i love colby you know
this
when i was in miami on tour me and kobe
got together i absolutely adore the guy
i i think he's such a good person you
know what what you guys see on camera is
not colby he's obviously come up with
this gimmick and it works because you
guys pay to watch him lose so he's uh
he's getting the laugh
laughed there but i do think for him if
he does want the title shot it's going
to go through hamzat i think he'd be
willing to take that shot if the ufc
tells him if dana goes all right dude if
hamza does what we think is going to
happen against gilbert burns
you you're gonna fight hamza and you get
another title shots the only way you can
get another title shot i think you'd be
willing to take that
and i agree with you i think it's gonna
take something like that some kind of
creativity within the negotiation oh hey
daniel i heard what you said what does
this mean tell me what it means if i
beat jeremiah you don't think i'm going
to beat him you're trying to build him
i'll take the risk i agree with you i
just think he needs to get it stated
ahead of time it's still a hard path to
get back to usman and frankly even if
the bosses say look this is the number
one contenders i do think usman's
opinion matters and if who's wants to go
look colby is the hardest fight i've
ever had i barely got away with it i did
it again i didn't want to but i did and
i got away with it twice i'm not
fighting him again i think we would
listen to that i mean if i was to put
myself in the shoes of oozman there are
some close ones in sport you go out take
those risks but if you get a guy in your
rear view he's in your rear view i mean
in all fans i think there's a
conversation i think if you're kobe
you're probably crossing your fingers
one to find a path like you and i just
laid out where at least the opportunity
exists but two that somebody gets that
belt off of kamara or that kamara's hand
injury just by example it doesn't heal
in time and they bring in an interim
championship i think they're more likely
paths back to a championship fight it's
just hard but you've already done it
twice and you didn't split in this
sports history it's hard to get numbers
i i feel for colby because you know he's
going for these big fights and then no
one's really biting especially your boss
you know dana white's like we're good on
that man those go nowhere but you know i
don't think kobe just wants to wait
around you know for these other
contenders to get their stuff together
and you know be good opponents um
you know outside that i thought with uh
the komen event dos anjos i'll see dos
angelos faziva would have been a
fantastic fight doesn't happen um you
know so does sanchos takes another short
notice fight it shouldn't have been five
rounds you know i think with dos anjos
for him with the physique he goes i'm
good man i'm good that's in the rear
view we've tried doing it twice now it's
not happening you know i like this call
out of mcgregor or makachov uh makachev
i think those would be great fights for
him um i just don't know
again what the ufc wants to do with dos
anjos
well what an incredible game of chicken
i mean michael chef calls out rda puts
one stipulation that the weight class
has to be 170. rda says okay
and michael jeff doesn't show up i mean
that's a win on the playground right the
best general never fires a shot they
just align their troops and make the
other side back down that's a win for
rda then rda goes in uh into this fight
look i don't like the five round idea i
don't like it anywhere i don't like it
in main events i don't like it in
championship fights i came through the
era where we in mma were trying to
compare our sports to others well the
super bowl isn't five quarters just
because it's the championship game the
gold medal for the 100 yard dash doesn't
become 103 yards because the
championships on the line i've never
fully understood that i also see
commissions and i get that the
commission's number one interest is
commerce but they hang their hat to get
taxpayer dollars on fighter safety
nothing would make the sport safer than
putting a guy out there for less time so
i just don't love that concept i don't
love that that round went forward that
fight went five rounds nobody wanted to
be out there less than rda and if you go
look at the fifth round where it looked
as though his opponent was surviving rda
quit fighting
rda was trying to run off the clock and
help that guy when he did touch him it
was no faster than this now moy econo
started throwing some heat and rda had
to defend himself but rda didn't even
want to hit him anymore and i'm going
where's the adult in the room we got the
best referee in the business when big
john isn't doing it we got a fantastic
doctor they've had not one but two
conversations and still didn't stop it
that should be a sign to the corner man
and brennan i don't hang my hand on this
whole let a fighter show his heart a
fighter having heart and a quarterman
having no heart do not have to be the
same thing get your guy out of there
when he can no longer win not when he
can no longer fight when your guy can no
longer win get him to the back it's your
job i think it's a problem in our sport
you know i think boxing is a little more
leniency with that where they well
thrown the towel with mma especially in
the ufc it's very rare you see that i
think it's a huge
ego thing and it's just you know the
cornerman never wants to take that
responsibility but as a cornerman you
you
that's you that's your that's your
number one job is to protect that
fighter it's it's a really kind of a
black guy i think i think a lot of a lot
more cornermen could really do their
fighters a service by throwing the towel
you know live to fight another day so i
i do like with rda
and before you came out i was breaking
down what what i think's next for
certain guys
and a name keeps popping up a name with
you know austin maslow's lost three in a
row now but he's the third highest
third highest contractor in ufc history
which i'd love to know the exact details
of because
guys made a ton of money you know i know
guys who make tons of money so when i
say third highest i'm like holy [ __ ]
that's a ton of money
but when you do get paid like that
you're gonna have to take big fights the
ufc is gonna have to get a return on
their on their investment so you're not
fighting young lions anymore you know
the mazda dolls can get these
blockbuster fights a fight that makes a
lot of sense for mozdale and rda would
be conor mcgregor you know he's been out
i really don't see conor coming back to
55. you look how juicy is right now he
looks you know bigger than he's ever
been i think the cut could be tough for
him i think a mazel doll fight makes a
lot of checks every single box for both
guys i could see that from oswald
exceeded for rda2 and again before you
answer i think for connor if you're
conor fan which i'm a huge connor fan
even you know with his crazy antics he's
been doing
i do think those are winnable fights for
him you know when when he called out
mock chef i went that you don't want
that that's not what we want to do here
you're not going to get a win there rda
could see a win mazda could see a win
tough fights but winnable
i fully agree with you and just to
remind the audience the entire conor
experimented 170 was predicated on dana
white going out to dinner in beverly
hills and some guy jumping in front of
him with a camera who happened to work
for tmz so uploaded on tmz they asked
about mozville and they asked dana would
you ever put it with conor mcgregor dana
said no mozball's too big for him well
that upset conor connor took that as a
challenge in his very next fight which
happened to be against cowboy cerrone
was at 170 pounds the whole reason conor
came up to 170 was to dispute the fact
that david said mozball was too big so
you got the biggest star in the sport
conor mcgregor who wants to fight the
second biggest star in the sport in
george moswell i'm with you i even think
we've got a date i think international
fight week which is supposed to be the
biggest fight of the year i think that
we've got everything right conor puts
out that picture on instagram that you
referenced he claims to weigh 193 pounds
he looked like he weighed 193 pounds go
part way down
jump in there at 170. i am with you that
that's the fight to make but brenda
we're the only ones talking about it i
can't believe
that more people are banging for that
including conor including moswell so
let's say we don't get it if anybody
knows how to do the sport the punches
and the kicks and the grappling the
conditioning it's rda if anybody doesn't
understand the business of the sport
it's rda he's not demanding these things
if you go look at the lifting that rda's
done literally if you go to sherdog
right now type in rda's name under fight
finder if you look at who he fought and
when he fight them he's gone through two
divisions every champion and every
contender at 55 and
70. it is remarkable the work that this
guy's put in but he doesn't make these
demands he seems to go too far a lot of
guys too nice he's too nice he's too
nice about it i think he needs to quit
being so nice i think the mere fact that
he backed down michael jeff and defeated
moycano in one week should scream
volumes he's a main event fighter he
deserves a big fight now he's got to
play the game to figure out how he gets
it yeah i think for rda because he is so
nice and i do you know we again before
he came out i'm saying rda has as far as
strength of schedule has the best ever
in ufc history 5570 by far the best
resume you could possibly have
he's going to need a guy in
connor who calls the shots right
they're going to it's not like they're
going to come to connor go right rda or
mazdal connor's going to make that
decision so i think if connor's team
gets wind of rda's in that the only way
this happens is if conor gets win and
starts promoting this thing asking for
the fight
but again as much as i love rda and he
he treated me so nice when i fought no
garen brazil he was literally the only
brazilian that would take me to places
where they wouldn't poison my food so
i'm forever grateful to him but i think
that just it to me it's a no-brainer
again you see nobody's talking about it
but you and i are
it's connor mozart all
international fight week that thing's
it's gonna do gangbuster numbers man
oh it's massive i mean that is the fight
to make and i feel as though people
forget that's why i took the time to
bore you with the timeline of that story
but that's literally what happened dana
was going to dinner dude jumps out dana
takes time to answer it turns out dude
works for tmz connor hears about it
loses his mind it comes and fights at
170 i mean that fight is all but done
now let's try to make the case for rda
because one thing that rda has on his
side is he's got pictures worth a
thousand words he's got the photo shoot
of him and conor don't forget those two
are supposed to fight are you getting
hurt right he ends up getting pulled out
of it but that fight was promised to him
for him to come back and claim was once
already his i think that it's fair he
needs to tell that story it's not going
to be simple you got to get conor's
attention everybody comes to conor and
there's nothing that connor likes more
than to be challenged and to dismiss a
guy so you really got to be strategic
with the call out you got to know how
you're going to do it once you get met
with rejection you've got to hit him
again and again and again but if you
insult conor the right way he is like
any
excuse me like any wounded animal he's
going to come out and fight you i just
think it's a tricky game and even if
it's not conor for rda i think we can
all agree it needs to be something big
i'm all of a sudden interested in islam
versus rda what is it that islam saw
that made him go back on his own idea
i'm interested in that i gotta fight for
a world title against jon jones because
that happened i didn't belong in there
with jon jones in all fairness and i
knew it ahead of time but john turned me
down in the in the public's eye the
public said whoa what does john c i mean
i'm just speaking from firsthand uh
knowledge it's it's a real thing when a
guy says no we go wait wait a minute why
not i think that rda's got big fights
out there but brendan to your point he's
got to quit being so nice and here's the
problem with him being so nice be
careful what you asked for because if
you don't build up that connor fight
you're gonna get makachev and that is a
nightmare of a matchup man i again i
there's nobody higher on makachev and
hamzad than me though i i ride their
hairy nuts like you wouldn't believe
jail i love both those guys i don't see
a [ __ ] in their armor especially with
machiavelli has faced tougher
competition
but for rda it's like hey man if you
don't get on the on the bike here and
start screaming for connor you're going
to get makachev and it's not going to be
pretty dude so you better get on it and
there
there was one that went under the radar
but it was last week if there's anything
we know about khabib it's that he's a
man of his word if he says he's going to
do it he does it which included
retirement if he says it it's done
khabib came out and said i want conor to
fight islam and if conor loses to islam
i'll come out of retirement and avenge
it against conor i mean that's really
big news and that's a really big piece
of the story but once khabib says it he
really does mean i mean i think from the
world of promotion there's all the story
that we need and you can say whatever
you want about conor mcgregor he is not
afraid to fight he will take that fight
with islam if somebody asked him agreed
again terrible idea especially if you're
a conor fan it's just we need to get a
win here man we got to get a freaking
win it's not going to be maka chef dude
that's not what you want to do with your
career man it seems like a bad idea and
also i agree with you once khabib says
something that that's it man he says it
he he he'll do it
but he knows that makshev is a complete
nightmare for conor so the chance of
connor beat mokshev is not high so i i
think him saying that he's just trying
to get his boy eyeballs but also for the
ufc it's no matter what they decide to
do with connor it's basically a a
win-win for the ufc because connor
makchev even if makchev wins now you
have all the eyeballs on makachev you
know he's khabib's you know bassy little
brother and it's going to be a huge
pay-per-view you put them with mozville
the ufc makes all the money in the world
but the whole thing here depends how
much juice they see left in conor
because if you got to be strategic about
it and the best fight for conor the most
winnable fight again none of them are
easy but if you're a connor fan the
winnable fight probably mazvidal if you
had to guess maybe mazdal you know i
it's just it's a no-brainer to me man
yeah conor could definitely win that
fight i love the breakdown because
mozball is going to cope and stand with
him he's not going to try to double
cross and get a takedown and frankly his
wrestling isn't good enough that he can
just throw connor now connor's tough to
take down ask chad mendes ask khabib i
agree with you i like that fight and
another one i don't know that i would
predict for you that it's going to
happen but dana has not completely
thrown water on the idea of conor coming
in right against charles oliveira and
again with oliveira's wrestling or lack
thereof conor's big left hand i mean you
could start to break it down and start
to see ways i agree with you the michael
chip there's nothing to see here we're
gonna have fun we're gonna have a build
up we're gonna have five rounds going to
islam but there are still some some real
matches out there for mcgregor i'd like
to know where he is i'd love to know
what his motivation is they say a rich
man can't fight but floyd proved that to
be wrong and you know connor's following
that path now too if conor is truly
motivated and truly wants to be a
champion of the world that would mean
something to me i would want to hear
that i didn't love the way he prepared
for his last couple of training camps i
didn't love the fact that he left
ireland that's got the gym and all of
his coaches and went to another country
first inclusion i just didn't understand
it i didn't think he looked great
against dustin poirier but there's still
big things out there and i got to be
real real critical just to say that and
we're also proven i mean the one thing
that colby and george mossvall who just
sold 15 000 tickets six days in advance
of how the heavyweight championship sold
tickets the one thing they had in common
brennan is they're both coming off
losses the one thing they had in common
is between the two of them they hadn't
won a fight uh in the last three
boxing doesn't make losing acceptable
mma it is and it is because our fans
understand nobody gets built nobody gets
a free ride it's iron on top of iron
every night you're just not likely to go
undefeated in that way but it's a larger
part of the story but the guys that you
and i are sitting here discussing
admitting that we want to headline the
biggest card of the year which is
international fight week i haven't want
to fight between them since like 2018 we
don't care that's the fight to make
mozvo versus mcgregor coming up but i
think you brought up a great point for
connor it's like what is his motivation
if it's still money which would be
unbelievable if it is it has to be more
than money but if it is money mozville's
the the cash cow here that's the biggest
fight but if it's to be a world champion
then none of you know the rda the mazda
dolls the mock chevs none of this
matters because if it's not about money
it's just getting that title back you
know and being a world champion he's all
he's interested in is charles oliveira
that's all he cares about so that would
be the fight but again we haven't heard
from conor but if his motivation is just
to be a world champion
none of this other stuff matters what
we're talking about
sure sure if he could get a guarantee of
a number one contendership so i hear you
look i like the bmf belt i loved when
they brought it out i think it's
opportunity i'm one of the few guys i
like the interim title it just creates
opportunity i want him to resurrect the
bmf if the belt wasn't on the line so it
didn't go to us like some people think
it doesn't belong to covington the
title's got to be on the ric flair used
to get pinned one two three but he was
still the champion because the title
wasn't on the line i mean right the
interest is in the details here i think
they bring that back connor versus
george bmf title up for grabs i mean too
but would you be would you be open to a
mazda nate diaz rematch for bmf that
doesn't really that does nothing for me
that i like that and you want to know a
story that was getting out there and
then again at fizzle but was nick diaz
that nick was going to go against
mozville that was all the rage
that would have worked and nick has been
radio silent quite frankly nick looked a
lot better against robbie than i think
nick knew when nick sat down and said i
had i had enough i'd be curious i never
checked the scorecards that is public
but i had it at one a piece i thought
that it was one and one and we're going
to the third i thought nick looked
really good but nick has been radio
silent dana made one comment on him and
said i don't know if nick's ever going
to fight again
it seemed like nick who'd been removed
for a period of time which is why he was
a little bit rusty wouldn't want another
break he'd want to get right back in
there and i thought maybe there would be
some opportunity for mozball versus big
brother
i love that fight but i also thought
that nick didn't want to fight that
that's what i again i have no clue i
don't have an end to the diaz camp but
from the rumors i heard was nick's not
really interested in fighting he took
that fight to pay off some loan or some
crazy thing like that who knows what's
true but if that is true that's why
you're seeing this long layoff he's
probably not coming back
that would make a level of sense i was
very light on that idea just the work
that he went through just to get back i
thought he did instagram and he was
looking great and he did a couple of
triathlons so i thought when a guy's
sharp and a guy wants to come back you
know even if it is for the money i'm
okay with that but what's what's better
than one paycheck is two paychecks but
the mere fact that he's taking a break
and been very quiet maybe that's the
true rumor maybe he just doesn't want to
do this anymore i'm okay with it
larger point that i'm trying to prove
with you is there's a lot of really good
options right now they don't all have to
be world championship related are our
sport's three biggest stars conor
mcgregor followed by mozville followed
by anybody with the last name of diaz
they're not championship guys they have
not won a period of time our audience
decided we don't care these are the guys
we like in this order so any part of
that parody that you can put them
together makes good sense to me brother
i know i know you gotta get going
because you have espn show so i'll let
you get out of here soon i just want to
ask you a few more questions and you let
me know just cut me off whenever you
want
with francis ingano adam on food truck
recently and and flashback fight nights
right after his win he came uh to the
thick boys studios
how do you see that going down in a in a
perfect world i would love for francis
and the ufc to figure out a deal
you know i i know from very close
sources uh with the tyson fury team they
want that fight that fight's happening
they that is good is done that's gonna
he's gonna fight i think dylan white he
says he's gonna retire then people go
what about francis goes i'm retiring
from boxing to me that's not a boxing
fight that's something else but that's
happening we i know for a fact talking
to francis team i'm very close with and
tyson's team that fight it you're you
are going to get that fight to me that
the that fight
is going to be so much bigger so much
more
special if the ufc
machinism is involved like the connor
floyd mayweather fight so i would love
for france to figure out a deal with the
ufc where they're going to play ball and
it doesn't sound like he's asking for
for a crazy amount of money either i
think he's just asking for more money
which is you know every fighter wants
more money i would just love for them to
figure out a common ground where he
fights jon jones you know fights uh
really jon jones is the fight for him at
heavyweight and then also the ufc and uh
tyson fury and cahoots when they do
fight i i don't want to see a world
where francis goes out signs with
somebody else or he doesn't have the
backing of the ufc and fights tyson fury
i don't want that i'm too big of a ufc
fan
i see that too it's very hard to be mad
at francis in this one thing francis has
done is he's remained polite
he hasn't called names he hasn't raised
his voice he shared with us the audience
the inner intricacies of his contract
which was none of our business but now
he let everybody know here's where i'm
at i'm going to renegotiate here's what
i'm going to ask for it's real hard to
be mad at francis now i don't see a
value in francis sangano going over in
boxing i don't see a value in conor
mcgregor fighting floyd mayweather i see
a value with a lot of commas and zeros
in the city reigning ufc world champion
going over and doing something else i
also think it's a big mistake by those
guys to not make it boxing tyson fury's
to come out and said we're gonna do it
in four ounce gloves and we're gonna
change all the rules but that becomes a
problem you and i who are on the
internet we're big influencers and big
voices in this sport we can cover it if
we want but what do you do at
sportscenter what does jim rome do what
does dan levitar do that are talking to
the audience i mean what do you call
that if we're not calling it boxing and
we're not calling it mma what are we
trying to tell the fans that they're
going to go and do and also what's on
the line there's got to be something at
risk if tyson fury wants to put his
beautiful record up for grabs that's a
storyline but if we're going to call it
a different sport and regardless of the
outcome it doesn't reflect the sport
that tyson's dedicated his life to i
just think it's weird i i don't know why
they would if you change one rule you've
now changed the sport i think you've got
to put it in the gloves of which francis
isn't going to care titus and fury comes
from a sport where they negotiate the
ounce of the gloves they negotiate if
they're made in china or if they got
horse hair or if they were made of
mexico they watch the opponent put it on
we don't do that at mma we don't give a
goddamn you set up the rules and we'll
come fight you it is the major
difference between us and boxers and i'm
not sure that tyson knows that so don't
change anything keep it at a 17 by 17
ring keep it ten rounds three minutes
with a one minute break keep it boxing
keep it a sport don't go make up
something if you're gonna make something
up you guys might as well go arm wrestle
we don't care something has to be at
risk and i do think that francis needs
to do it as the ufc champion not just as
francis and ghana a guy with a zero and
zero boxing right hundred percent but
and i also think that's where the
influence of dana white and the ufc
would come into play and go no no we're
not doing this weird [ __ ] with this
weird rules and different gloves i would
imagine you know no one's better
promotional uh
entertainment than dana white and he
knows if you make this thing
confusing for the casuals that what is
it it's the the former ufc champion
fighting in four ounce gloves inside
what is it in a cage what are we doing
here you're gonna miss out on the
casuals and that's where they're gonna
make their their their big payday so
that again that's another reason i would
love for them to figure out a deal i
really do i hope it works out and i
think it is going to work out
hopefully rather sooner than later but
the big thing is is is the comeback of
jon jones and it sounds like you know
depending where they're at with francis
john's going to probably fight stipe
that's the rumor i don't know you know
more than i do you work for him but you
know i think john stipe makes a lot of
sense are you are you a fan of that
fight for john
big fan i think the only question we're
figuring out is are we fighting for the
interim championship or the undisputed
championship if francis really is going
to lock in and not come back we might
have to take the belt off of him i mean
i think in all fairness the other side
is france has just fought andy's hurt
everybody else gets a period of time you
get to rehab you get to talk not just
because you say certain things to the
media they take the belt off you but i
do feel like that's the delay stipe has
been oddly quiet and jon jones has been
oddly quiet generally when that happens
it's because a deal's already done and
they've been told don't say anything
we're going to release this if i was to
predict you with my limited information
that i just laid out what the hold up is
i think that's it we don't know to make
the announcement if it's for the intro
or if it's for the undisputed strap but
that's the fight to make i got one
source in it which is stipe's wife she
and i are pen pal she told me in no
uncertain terms we're here in jon jones
and we're prepared to fight him i also
asked her by the way one thing that
stipe said after he fought francis and
ghana he was seeing the path back to his
championship is going through francis
it'd be a true trilogy fight they both
split let's go to number three he said
i'm going to put on 20 pounds i'm going
to put it on the right way though i'm
going to put on 20 pounds of muscle
stevie miocic at 2
55 is a very different steep a than the
236 that he fought francis at i like
that idea now i'm told that stipe has
already succeeded his wife said he's got
on the right side he's very lean so a 2
55 stipe versus a 240 john jones man i'm
in for that all day i like that match-up
i love it i i it's too close to break
down right now i
i'm usually hesitant just from my own
experience when the guys put on weight
they get slower their cardio is not as
good and maybe for stipe's like you know
i'm going to knock guys out so i'm
putting on more weight you know john
said he wants to get up to 280 put on
all this weight when i hear that i i
kind of i flinch a little bit because
i'm like john
your advantage that heavyweight is your
your fighting iq is gonna be second to
none your your creativity and then also
your speed and quickness if you get big
like all the other heavyweights you're
just another guy my man like you we
don't want to take away what's going to
make you special at heavyweights so i
don't like it when guys put on weight
but i do think stipe at you know at the
latter part of his career makes a little
sense there but i would absolutely be
stoked if that fight comes to fruition
steve bayvis john sign me up all
freaking day man take my money yeah and
as you say we've got a lot a lot of time
to talk here but i don't know if a
weigh-in would ever be more relevant
than between those two because i'm with
you i think that jon jones is a rare
talent i think jon jones 220 225 when he
weighed when he cut to 205 i think it
was enough i think he could have picked
apart a lot of guys i think he could
have used that speed his endurance
doesn't work overly hard by reputation
but boy he never gets tired on fight
night i thought those were his
advantages he wanted to change his
physiology and that wasn't from a
physical standpoint it was just
psychologically john thought i need to
be bigger okay i'm up for the experiment
but stephen miocic got so small he
weighed in at 231 pounds for his third
fight with daniel cormier that was
stunning we all thought he went on like
a vegan diet or he had changed how are
you so small he finally answered the
question he said none of those things he
said i'm eating all of the same foods
we're just working really hard this is
just what i went all right i'll accept
that but to remind you he wants to get
back to 255 when he did some of his best
work he was 248 so i do think that
bigger stipe is a better step and if the
entire allure to jon jones at this
weight class is how can he do against a
bigger man we need to make sure the man
is bigger and right now with john
claiming on instagram he's 242 and
stife's last fight went at 236 right now
we don't fulfill that john's still the
bigger man so i really am interested in
the weight of both guys yeah i think too
again uh to wrap this up with with john
i've trained with john i've seen john
spar some of the greatest heavyweights
that we've ever seen inside that ufc
octagon in a shark tank round big boys
man and absolutely manhandle them didn't
lose a single round shark tank he stays
in
world-class heavyweights coming in him
tossing people around man so that's why
i'm like you don't need to do all this
dude you're right you're good to go
right now sign sealed delivered you're
ready to go be ufc heavyweight champion
right now and then you win that fight
and friend that's where i think france's
team needs to realize if john is who he
says he is and who i believe he is you
know outside all the uh the outside
shenanigans which is a whole other story
but if john gets his [ __ ] together and
beats stipe which is tough but if he
does
jon jones francis
for in it's in if him and uh stipe fight
for the interim belt france has the real
belt jon jones francis dude we're going
sizzler and then so not only do you have
jon jones francis but then you also got
the fury fight so if i'm the ufc and i'm
francis the ufc how much freaking money
are we going to make off francis
re-signing with us let's pay him what
what you know what he wants and then
also that that fury fight i mean dude
you're talking about history dude i'm
i'm all for it i hope they figure it out
i really do i'll get you
brad
i think you're right and i think francis
can get there i'm just wondering the
order of it like let's say francis
exhausted his contract and he does the
fury business if he loses to fury he's
hard to bring back right i mean people
are still going to view that as a loss
if he beats fury and every promoter
vince mcmahon does this more than any
promoter it's why he let rock go over
there what happens if he loses okay but
what happens if brock wins and i got him
under contract so if francis was to beat
fury and then return i mean right
francis can still get his way it's a
risky game it's a little too rich for my
blood and i'm a gambler but it's
possible brendan it could happen yeah
yeah never say never but man that is a
tough hill to climb there man you got a
big right hand you don't think fury's
seen that he just dismantled deontay
wilder who has a giant right hand and is
a you know he's a world champion boxer
so you come from the ufc you think
you're gonna land that
hopefully he does you know and tyson
fears my favorite fighter whether it's
mma or a box and i absolutely love fury
i'll i'll end on this
you know obviously it's uh
it it it's a dark way to end our
conversation you know i love you but
with with cain velasquez
it's just such a tragic story man it's
such a tragic tragic story and i talked
to to a lawyer about this because you
know i reached out to dc and josh
thompson are very close with kane
velazquez i said how can i help man what
can i do what do you need me to raise
money you need my lawyer i have big
high-profile lawyers they're based out
of la they work with the biggest names
in the business how can i help man let
me know what i can do
and so i talked to my lawyer
and he goes
it's this is a very black and white
situation clearly you know obviously
keynes ufc alumni and you love the guy
and stuff like that because the law
doesn't care it's very black and white
the premeditated stuff where he had days
to think about this and put together a
plan that's what's gonna screw him so
you have to hope it goes to a jury
because obviously you know uh a a child
of his or a family member was molested
by this man
you have to hope it goes to a jury and
they have compassion and they give them
a lesser sentence you gotta pray to god
it goes to a jury it's just the whole
situation is just heartbreaking man it's
absolutely heartbreaking
it's tough this would be a shot in the
dark i don't predict for you this would
happen but in the best case scenario the
family and the person who is accused who
says i didn't do it i mean we kind of do
owe it to him he says he didn't do it
he's been convicted of nothing
cain shot the wrong guy
it's hard to make a case he shot the
wrong person not to mention it was in
public where those bullets could have
gone anywhere and it turns out our
friend velasquez ain't that good at
eamonn no but imagine a scenario where
the guy who was accused the family of
the guy was accused comes in to court
and testifies for kane
they say look we didn't do this but we
understand the fury we love children too
this was a misunderstanding please go
light on him and you have a sympathetic
jury i mean i'm saying a lot of butts
right now i'm saying a lot of ifs it's a
hard spot it is pretty black and white
i'd like to make a case for kane the
best or least that i could do is to tell
the world what a nice man this is what a
cool man this is regardless to what you
saw on television this was a bad moment
brendan if i could go back if i would if
i had a magic wand to go back and this
never happened that would be best
because he
he shot a guy that
or shot at a guy who is not yet
convicted who says he's innocent we got
to give him that and secondly he hit the
wrong guy it's a tough spot brendan yeah
and to to your point and i'm just again
i i don't i'm not a lawyer this will
surprise you guys i'm not a lawyer but
is there a world where
kane could offer a settlement to the
family or because this is
about are we past that can you offer a
settlement yeah yeah we're past that
we're past we're past that but there
could be some room to talk if somebody
there understood and goes look your mind
was a mess let me explain you what
happened for mice right i mean sometimes
you do get people that are reasonable
but most times people just go this
happened to me and i'm coming back for
justice but some people are reasonable
maybe kane could do a settlement in
exchange come in and tell this to the
judge hey we understand why he had lost
his mind he operated on information he
had we don't agree with that information
but we do understand if he believed that
he did what he thought a father could do
i mean in this kind of a situation only
a jury
is going to let cain see the light of
day in the next decade he's probably
going to sit yeah because premeditated
minimum sentence 15 years my man you
just hate to see it you hate to see it
because
you know i don't know if it was his son
daughter whatever family member but now
that child has grown up without a father
because of these actions so
you know it's just a lose-lose situation
man and you know i know and i do think
you can start to work backwards by the
way i mean right now he's a he's a
premeditated murderer if kane could
convince somebody no well i shot exactly
where i meant to hit him i never
intended to kill him it's assault with a
deadly weapon it's not a lot better i'm
just sharing for you in the world of law
we can start to work down and i don't
know that he has to sit on on
premeditated he certainly didn't attempt
to to kill the guy who he shot the wrong
guy but you can start to work backwards
where this was reckless this was a
deadly weapon this isn't going to be
great but it's not what we're sitting on
today yep i just you know i pray for the
guy that i hope it works out man you
hate to see it jail i love you man what
do you got now you got espn stuff what
are you just chatting about colby
i did espn i'm gonna do teddy atlas's
show i got invited by the way you paid
me a nice compliment at the beginning of
the show you said josh barnett said some
nice things about me that made me feel
wonderful i just wanted to give a shout
out josh barnett top three fighter ever
if you discuss the top three
heavyweights ever and you don't put josh
barnett on your list i feel you lose
credibility that meant a lot to me that
he said something nice so thank you for
yeah josh loves you matt matrione loves
you and have you had josh on any of your
shows
i've had joshua yes uh when i very first
started a podcast he came on very early
you know he's such an interesting smart
guy yeah he's
pro wrestling like he's really diverse
he's a curious guy he's a great mind
sometimes i feel that he gets excluded
from our community and i don't know why
because he's one of the most
knowledgeable guys within the entire
sport and when when he starts to share
his ideas and visions man the guy's sure
i love josh barnett man i love you too
brother and i wish next time let's do
this in person man i know you're swamped
and we got busy schedules but let's
figure it out i'm never too busy for you
and i love you too thank you brandon to
talk to you
there you have it one of my favorite
people on the planet chael sonnen none
better than chael to break down
anything when it comes to the fight game
he'll see has been in the biggest fights
of all time with anderson silva jon
jones nate marquardt um to just name a
few i absolutely love chael sonnen and
also he's a kobe compton expert that's
his boy so um wanted him on here after a
big colby count and fight
and uh he made some good points man you
know colby's kind of in this weird
position and it's gonna be interesting
to see what they do with them it really
is so shout out to chelsea go like
subscribe to his podcast to me he's the
most entertaining best doing it uh in
our sport so go like and subscribe to
chelsen's youtube channel and his
podcast and the guy's crushing i
absolutely love him and uh that's the
show that's it my man few housekeeping
notes uh i will be in nashville
tennessee at zany's this thursday friday
saturday um all shows are damn near sold
out uh friday night late show we have a
good amount of tickets left so get on
those right now nashville those shows
will sell out can't add more shows i
just can't do it so get your tickets
right now at thickboy.com
um and then the wednesday uh this
wednesday i'll beat the improv shop and
friends jeff dye
trevor wallace chris delia brian callan
chappelle lacy the boys are all there
one night one show only 8 p.m hollywood
improv that's this wednesday then
thursday friday saturday nashville i end
the month in chicago at the schomburg
improv thursday friday saturday chicago
so get your tickets at thickboy.com uh
check out the recent food truck on thick
boy with michael chandler and then we
also got the cobb ass fight command with
the war master himself josh barnett and
matt matrione go check all that out at
thinkboy.com
like subscribe do your thing thanks for
watching thanks for listening shout out
to chelsen love you guys stay safe stay
thick
you